the Joe Rogan experience that's
hilarious
so what's happening man you just got off
of the chan-sung Jung fight and what's
next what are you up to I'm gonna go
down 35 yeah you know how much to walk
around it I'm probably like 56 right now
Wow you know so for 45 interval
Marlon's got to be bigger than you right
Marlon is about a little bit bigger than
me yeah I think so I think he walks her
a little heavier he's a little bit more
of an eater and I am did that guy I can
I have a hard time believing he makes 35
sometimes he will yeah he's so Jack got
such a small waist no mum he soaked his
legs and shoulders are so big but his
waist is kind of small so maybe that's
how he carries it so have you done a cut
like that before I haven't been but I
mean my last fight I think I was you
know getting down the 45 got down to
like forty four point five I mean it's
only eight and a half over where I gotta
be free to make 36 and it was such an
easy cut for this last time so it's
you're you're an interesting situation
man because like you won the title at 55
and you didn't cut any weight at all and
a lot of people who like well [ __ ] man
Frankie I think if you do because you
the thing about you at 55 is you were so
durable like that was one of the
craziest things about some of your
fights like the gray Manor fights yeah
[ __ ] a man who wrapped those fights
um Yves Lavigne both of them know the
first one the first second one I think
was Josh Rosenthal
well shout out to both of those guys
because a trigger hungry referee who's
got an itchy trigger finger they would
stop those fights now I think nowadays
someone might stop it yeah yeah then I
feel like they let it go a little more I
mean so of course there's still some
times to let it go a little you never
know it all changes it's such a weird
thing right it's like the referee is
trying to help the fighter they're
trying to make sure that the fighter
doesn't take unnecessary damage but you
know more than once you see fights
stopped way like oh that guy wasn't done
right he was he was getting through a
bad patch and that's part of what a
fight is about it's like trying to
figure out how to survive for sure I
always want to bend in for the doubt I
you know yeah I don't want to get
unnecessary punishment of course but I'd
rather get the benefit that I've never
been turned off even with Ortega and
chan-sung Jung fight I got right both
those fights even though I got rocked
and my other fights these fights I kind
of
more coherent I'm not complaining about
the stoppages or anything like that you
know I could see why they stopped it but
in the gray fights even the Benson
Henderson fight where I got up kicked I
don't remember any of those fights you
know I remember like three four rounds
of those fights just because it was so
wild is getting hit yet because I got
hit and I kept getting hit maybe maybe
that's why I remember the Ortega fight I
got rocked pretty good and I remember in
my head saying alright short time left
let's get through let's get through it
obviously didn't make it to the end and
you know but I did I remembered being
coherent even this last one would but uh
Korean Zombie
I remember the ref saying you know you
got to do something down there you got
to do something down there and I was
trying to do my best and when body maybe
wasn't reacting to I need anything me
but uh yeah you know I never been turned
off you know I don't know if that's a
good thing or not but I know if it's a
good thing either it's like some people
say if you get turned off it's better
because then you you're you don't absorb
as much punishment or I heard that
argument but then if you do get turned
off your body gets turned off easier
next time that's that's pretty true yeah
like yeah I get cracked it can't kind of
continue to get cracked and get rocked a
little easier I'm hoping that's not the
case for me well it's not it's more of
the actual knockout itself yeah like
yeah I think a bit like a bad knockout
yeah it's crazy that you have had a
bunch of fights we don't remember most
of the fight like that that's the thing
that a lot of fighters don't necessarily
talk about but it's a reality of hard
fights yeah the my second fight with
grey were evolving was the the referee I
remember I think the fourth round mark
my coach mark was like you know telling
me we got one more round
in my head I'm like one more round what
happened to three and four
I didn't wonder at all and also I when I
dropped me I rolled my ankle really bad
probably a grade two sprain and I
remember in the fourth round coming to
and my ankle was hurt men like what
happened I have no idea what my ankle
and even got walking back you know I was
just kind of you know I don't know
sometimes you get rocked you get
depressed for some reason I noticed that
even in the gym when they get what I get
rock they get a little bit of depression
going on for some reason like what does
it feel like when you say depression
like why God why middle ball you know
you just down
you know I was emotional I think I was
crying after the great fight in the
locker room I think they have camera
back there and there's a video of me the
second fight when you stopped him not
the second fight but the the sec all
that that was the second fight nothing
never fight the third fight you stopped
the second fight you want the [ __ ]
fights that you had with gray were so
crazy they were soaked he was so big
yeah he's a big boy man I was so big for
55 you know and you were a guy didn't
cut any weight at all nothing I was
little you eat breakfast on Wayne day
wow that's crazy yeah we did you ever
think back then about dropping down what
were you just like [ __ ] I'm the champ
well that's why I was like a champ why
should I go down I mean I'm winning I'm
beating these guys yeah even the best
hand fights they were super close you
know I could have went either way and
but I just felt you know alright I'll go
down now I lost two in a row here but
you know what more can I gain from here
let me go down to 45 and that's that's
when I fought Aldo for it for the UH for
the 45 pound belt when you think about
it like if you had a chance to do it all
over again like if you had to engineer
your career all over again would you do
it exactly the same way would you fight
a 55 well you definitely would against
BJ right yeah I mean I I can't you can't
go back and change this right now it all
worked out for me you know I got a world
title
I had a printing to have a pretty good
career there's always things you wish
you could do differently you know you
just I can't be that guy that's gonna
say I wish I did this wish that things
went the way they went well they went
pretty [ __ ] good
[Applause]